this class is called introduction to
physical computing you learn how to
build things to react to things that are
in the computer world and then you learn
how to do things in the computer world
to control and do things in the physical
world we partnered with the Osher
Institute immediately across the hall
from the physical computing labs to get
six older people who are interested in
collaborating with undergraduates in
this class it helps students understand
that like they can do human centered
design to get them oriented in their
thinking towards being of service
towards the people around them when I
met with the team they came to my home
and I introduced them to the center of
my life right now which happens to be my
looms we realized that one of the big
things that stops her from starting a
project is needing to sit there and
start winding all the balls it's also
helpful because as my body ages my
arthritis kicks in I have seen electric
ball winders on the market for upwards
of six hundred dollars it's just too
expensive
every thing about this that's different
than what's in the market is that it
measures systems to pick motorized ball
winders you just wind them and stop them
when you want to but you can never know
how much is on there it probably will
extend my ability to keep weaving for
years to be able to do that and learn so
many skills along the way for that to
happen I think is really valuable and
really cool